c'est la première réaction de Vladimir
Poutine à la mort annoncé de Yevgeni
Prigogine lors d'une réunion télévisée
le président russe évoque la relation
qu'il entretenait avec son ancienne
homme de main devenu un traître à ses
yeux depuis sa mutinerie il y a 2 mois
c'était un homme au destin compliqué qui
a commis de graves erreurs pendant sa
vie il obtenait les résultats qu'il
fallait pour lui-même et quand je lui ai
demandé pour la cause commune comme il
l'a fait ces derniers mois c'était un
homme et un businessman talentueux
Vladimir Poutine le promet l'enquête sur
le crash de l'avion de Prigogine ira à
son terme
nous verrons ce que les enquêteurs
diront dans un avenir proche
l'expertise est en cours une expertise
technique et génétique cela prendra un
certain temps
24 heures après la disparition de prix
gaugine les causes du crash qui a causé
sa mort reste inconnue mais nombre
d'observateurs l'affirment le patron de
Wagner et son bras droit Dimitri outkine
ont été victimes d'une vengeance du
Kremlin une version reprise à demi-mot
par certains soutiens du milliardaire
venus lui rendre hommage devant le
quartier général de Wagner à
Saint-Pétersbourg
ils ont peur ils sont jaloux voilà tout
qui a peur ceux qui sont au pouvoir
d'après des sources au sein du
renseignement américain le crash a été
possiblement causé par une explosion une
information encore à confirmer